the the social media following and the
celebrity
makes my deal making better because i
could i can deliver the company's
extraordinary reductions in customer
acquisition costs
you can't run around all day long
worrying what people think about you
i don't you should not spend your day
trying to make
people like you that is a waste of time
[Music]
who do you i mean i know the statistics
and everything but who do you feel like
when you're sitting there you come
up against the most like just in your
mind like who are you always it's down
to like you and someone else like who do
you lose deals do you feel the most
out of your fellow sharks well i i think
that the most
difficult shark to circumvent is mr
wonderful
he's the guy i look out for and um i
always want to do deals with him he's my
favorite shark
listen he's a great shark what is the
first
tell us one word that comes to mind when
you think of like robert damon lori
mark like each of them when you work
with somebody for this
long 13 years that's
that's more than most people work with
anybody i mean this is like
um most people move jobs after three or
four or five years but
we've been doing this together for a
very long time and so
and we've built this incredible
following and we know each other's
um banter but but what might
makes it so interesting is each year
it's never predictable i mean it's just
something happens something changes
something occurs
i don't it just you know and we stay in
touch during the year but i will say
this
everybody's lives are so busy because of
shark tank
that we've never been able to get them
back in a room during the off season
not even once never you can't get them
all together because
we're just buried in stuff we're doing
and
we just can't get to the same city at
the same time so
that that moment when we all arrive um
this year it'll be in july in los
angeles
it's pretty it's like you're it's like a
uh you know summer camp reunion
and you know the thing is we work really
hard we get up at five in the morning
and we don't get home till ten at night
um and we just
the rest we we shoot three days in a row
and we're it's pretty tiring and then we
take a day off and we do
shoot another three days in a row and
it's very intense
and you need to stay sharp i remember in
the early years
um you know the second season maybe
we didn't really know each other so we
used to go out to dinner every night
together and
and one night uh damon and i
and mark and robert
i looked at my watch and it was 5 30 in
the morning
we were in a club and i went guys are we
shooting today and they looked at me and
said
yeah we had stayed up all night
and when i got to so we we realized we
got to get to the set in 45 minutes we
had no sleep and when i sat
in the makeup chair darcy said to me
you smell like a drunk
and that day of shark tank was one of
the best
we ever taped everybody was so hungover
that we just went at each other's throat
for blood and it was fantastic
television you know i'm not endorsing
going out and drinking all night i
couldn't even do that today
but it was one of those moments that
goes down in shark tank history
we'll never do that again i love it
what about the guest judges alex
rodriguez
have you ever met jennifer lopez kevin
yeah yeah she comes to the set he's
probably been on two or three times
she's there
i actually did a couple of awards show
with her she's a very nice woman there's
no question about it
but you know you the thing everybody
wants to come to the shark tank set
all the hollywood stars either see
themselves as a shark or you know they
want to pitch an idea
when we're taping because of cobit it's
not the same today but in the old days
every star in hollywood was at the shark
tank set you know john mayer would come
and we had everybody everybody's
everybody wants to sit in the chairs and
take that picture like this you know
and and it was just a rotating you know
carousel of of different artists and we
really enjoyed it because we'd have
lunch with
remarkable people nothing breeds success
like success
well maybe because she's already been to
set miss jennifer lopez could be a guest
shark
i would think she'd be a terrific shark
you know it's sort of um
and the thing you have to know about the
actual production
process is there are laws that stop the
producers from telling us
anything about what's going to happen
we don't know the deals we don't know
the guests they are announced to us you
know in a certain
with a certain protocol and that's
actually important for the show because
the discovery
of that deal we do that with you
we're discovering at the same time you
are when you're watching the show we've
never seen it before
and and that's very very important in
fact you're asked
to disclose have you ever talked to this
to any of the sharks about this
before and if you have you can't come on
the show what about
how was bethany frankel as a guest judge
well i know bethany quite well
uh actually i've done deals with bethany
we have we have a deal called snarky
tease together which is done quite well
so but you know everybody's their own
crazy chicken and she is definitely on
the scale of crazy chicken
that doesn't shock me what about the
fact you know she has this reputation of
being like very difficult
like difficult to like work with like is
that true nobody's difficult to work
with they're all competitors
nobody's the same and that's i think
it's the it's the unpredictability of
what's going to happen that makes the
show so interesting to watch you have no
idea what she's going to do
we've had plenty of guests that just are
stunned by you know they think they're
ready for it and then they just get
ripped to shreds and so
and it's really i'm happy to do i'm
happy to
to deliver that news to them no problem
what about you know while
we have david spade now who just
replaced chris harrison would you ever
host a show like the bachelorette or
bachelor
i'm just uh i just wrapped a pilot uh
for cnbc
called money court here in miami at the
telemundo studios
nbc universal uh think of judge judy on
steroids it's real business cases and so
in this case i'm a judge
um a real judge a mediator um these
these are contracts signed with these
disputes these are litigants that come
to the court i have
katie fang of legendary you know
reporter
slash lawyer a trial attorney and adam
pozzo who's the fed
was a federal judge so i've got real
legal talent beside me
uh we just finished taping it which is
why i'm in miami i'm doing some
follow-up
work for it it'll air august 11th on
cnbc i think people are going to be
stunned by
by what they see i mean i was not
prepared for what but what hit there and
then i got in the groove it was really
incredible
when people sue each other um
real litigation within families
sometimes between landlords and tenants
business partners it's really
nasty i mean there's the festering
wounds within family members
can be brutal a mother suing her
daughter can you imagine that
it's all captured there on money court
and i think it's going to be very very
engaging
it's sad to watch it happen but um but i
think i did good work in helping these
people find a resolution not everybody
agreed with the outcomes but uh
it's quite a show i get offered a lot of
properties a lot of shows uh
it has to be on brand for me it has to
kind of be it has to feel natural like
being a judge and mediating business
disputes is what i do every day in the
real world anyway so money court was a
natural fit
you know i want to pick projects that i
can grow i want
ownership in them i want to invest in
them
it's it's sort of the role of producer
and and
uh talent at the same time at the end of
the day i'm an investor
i i build businesses i build companies
and it has to kind of fit into that
and what we learned about shark tank is
there's a tremendous interest in
entrepreneurship there's
there's a lot of people that want to
pursue that path
and so shows that around that brand
are interesting but the granddaddy of
all this is shark tank uh you know that
platform is
i'm not going to do something that
competes with that i mean it's just too
big a platform
one day i was thinking of you know um
[Music]
branching out into something else and i
i called up lauren michaels who i
i don't know i knew who he was but the
great thing about being a shark is
everybody returns your calls it's
incredible and i asked him some advice
about branding
for television he said you know you're
the [ __ ] on shark tank
never ever give up the [ __ ] i said
that's very kind of you thank you are
there any guest
judges like we mentioned jennifer lopez
like do you have like an ideal
like hey i'd love to get this person on
shark tank or
and do a lot of people like a jennifer
lopez type or whoever like pitch you
like if you're out
you know like you said everyone wants to
come on shark tank
oh yeah i mean shark tank is not having
a hard time getting
uh you know products uh
they're just inundated with requests i
mean when you get to that iconic level
you get
thousands of of there's a a woman named
mindy casting who has cast
every single deal since the very first
one
she has a whole team of people it's like
american idol i go to a city they got a
thousand people lined up
and and she sees every single pitch can
you imagine that
so she then recommends them to the
producers is about 100 producers that
actually develop these things and get to
meet the entrepreneurs and do some
background checking and all the rest of
that
people don't understand the amount of
work that goes into making a show like
shark tank i mean it
you got to hand it to those producers
that's why they won for
you know what about like does anything
shock you in tv like you know like
bringing up bethany again like she just
had this huge you know seven-figure
rumor deal with mark burnett
big shot she had like this mgm
development deal and now
big shot i don't think it went so well
no shade
you know and now she's stepping away
from it the deal is over whatever
whatever the reasons for that are who
knows like are you shocked when
something is like so announced and it's
going to be huge
like bethenny and mark burnett how could
that fail i have been dealing with
uh hollywood for 15 years
nothing shocks me nothing nothing
i've seen everything um it is a very
flaky place i remember once
in season four i won't mention his name
but
anyways there was there was a ceo of of
abc
and i didn't want to have an agent
and i because i'm perfectly capable of
negotiating all my own deals i don't
need help
i don't need lawyers i don't need i'll
get them to pay for the deal after i'm
finished but i'll negotiate it myself
and so it was a you know when it was a
contract renewal for shark tank and what
and why would i want to pay
somebody to do that for me so i went to
tell them that at sony and abc
and at disney and i said i don't need an
agent they said
yeah you do i said why do i need an
agent
because we do not want to
deal directly with you your talent
you're nothing more than a piece of
meat and the sooner you realize that the
better
we'll trade you like a steak from one
shop one butcher to another we don't
care
um what's important is you have an agent
that has something to barter on your
behalf
and you don't have anything to barter
except your piece of meat
you're the only steak in your house we
want a butcher with many steaks
so that we can trade steaks that's how
brutal and blunt they were
and they were of course correct because
i wanted certain things
they didn't want to give them to me it
would have been a really bloody blowout
you know
discussion i would have maybe had
harvard uh difficult
feelings for those people that i need to
have good relationships for instead
my agent um a good one that i
basically met that not that day and and
decided to form a relationship with
did all that bloodshed for me and
ended up with a much better deal that i
could have never got
i remember seeing that executive the
next year and i said
and he said to me now what do you think
he visited the set we had a little
conversation that line she said now what
do you think was i right i said you were
right
the town doesn't change there's it
doesn't
change at all nothing changes the way
it's working now is the same way it
worked in the 40s
and the 30s and the 20s before there was
sound
it's a very closed secret
strange club and it ain't changing
ever i'm always interested in meeting
people that have a skill that you know i
don't have
or that they do something that really
interests me you know that i share like
watch collecting i have a massive watch
collection now
and so it and i think of it as an asset
and there's a lot of people in hollywood
that pursue some of these eclectic
things like guitars and all the rest of
that
but but mostly there's a downside to
celebrity and there's a positive side to
it the positive side is it opens a lot
of doors
uh the downside is most people think
they know you very well and of course
they don't
and that leads to uncomfortable moments
sometimes but you know all
in all i'm very proud of what i've
achieved in terms of television how i've
been able to combine
you know for me what this has done
because i'm primarily an investor
the the social media following and the
celebrity
makes my deal making better because i
could i can deliver the company's
extraordinary reductions in customer
acquisition cost
and that's how i've married the two and
so when people ask me about the downside
of you know of celebrity
i tell them if the offset is this
combination of of
investing with social media that's been
incredibly successful for me
and and i'm just you know i would have
never guessed it i
i didn't anticipate it i wasn't planning
for it but i have a whole team
of people that just do social now we
generate
a ton of content you know we're like a
network
we have so many different channels and
followings and strategies and social
media and podcasts and youtube and
linkedin influencing all this stuff
it takes many people to do that work
every day
you once said and like i said when i had
a company i worked 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days and i'm pretty much
there
right now i mean you've made statements
like this before is that the way of the
entrepreneur or
is there any other way like you
basically have seen you say things like
you just
that's what it takes you have to
sacrifice everything is that
true you think there is no other way um
it's a global competition
your competitor is going to work 25
hours a day eight days a week and if you
don't
they'll just kick your butt uh it is a
total commitment it is so
hard to do uh and and
the only way to know it is to do it and
it's it's not instant riches that's for
sure it's really it's
most entrepreneurs work for years before
they achieve success
it's tough but if if it's in your blood
then you pursue it and the outcomes can
be really good
and it lets you work harder at other
stuff i mean
i i just i go back to what i said you
know at the beginning of this
conversation it's it's a lifestyle it's
it's
not a destination it's a journey and you
have to be ready to
to go on that rocky road and all the
good and bad and ugly that comes with it
um add celebrity to it and it's even
crazier and so
it's just it is what it is and i live it
every day and i i suck it up and i enjoy
it not every day is a great day but
you know again i control my destiny and
i
i want that i you know that's that's
what matters to me these things matter
to me
and it lets me you know get every drop
out of life i can
the way i want to you can't run around
all day long worrying what people think
about you
i don't and so i learned that long long
time ago i think it's important to have
you know an arm's length and understand
that you should not spend your day
trying to make people like you that is a
waste of time
what do you think is like the biggest
mistake that entrepreneurs made
like is there one thing you see that
people just go wrong as an entrepreneur
they they believe their own [ __ ]
because they're out there spending a
story about how great their business is
going to be
when everybody knows you have to pivot
and whatever you thought was going to
happen
never happens so you have to be very
flexible and try and figure out what you
have to do
to make it work it's not easy what else
does mr wonderful do for fun i know you
know when you're building the business
you work 24 7 but you know you're in a
different situation now even though time
is still a problem but
i imagine you have some more time on
your hands than in the beginning like
what do you do on your time off
besides drink wine and travel yeah i
mean
you know i'm mostly starting new
businesses these days recently i've
become really interested in crypto and
i've started um
decentralized finance business i'm buyer
and i didn't start it but
i renamed it wonderfuy it was originally
called
d5 ventures now it's called wonderfuy
and somebody said
to me what are you trying to copy
bradson and i said yeah
i am i like his model and i like
wonderful and i think it can help brand
a lot of different things and now it's
wonderful
so you know i think we'll we'll be able
to acquire a lot of customers uh that
way and we'll see
you never know it's got risk to it but
um i know i know richard and i i think
what he did is brilliant and
i'm happy to copy something that works
why is it such a dirty thing for people
to say
i love money i want to be filthy rich
people don't want to just come out and
say that you have no problem saying that
why do you think people just can't say
that
well i say in the context of freedom you
need money to be free
and so i don't say i love money i love
freedom and along the way you have to
love money because that's how you get
free
but you shouldn't pursue
entrepreneurship for the greed of money
you should be pursuing it for the
passion of free
freedom and to do the things that matter
to you you know and then at some point
support the charities you care about
support the educational
initiatives you like support the arts
you like become a collector of watches
whatever it is
but none of that happens without you
know being in pursuit of money
uh in a business context you have to
make money you have to be profitable so
it's not a dirty word to me but the the
real
outcome of money is freedom and i put i
equate the two together and i being free
is the essence of the american dream
talk to us about shopmrwonderful.com i
know you mentioned that was coming
is that just for wines or is there more
that's going to be no it's everything i
you know
i tell people go visit my instagram
kevin o'leary tv
on my twitter any of that stuff you know
uh sign up youtube relationship
i'm i'm i'm always i'm constantly
putting out content about stuff i see
every day and i think
some people enjoy it it's it's an
interesting way of communicating with
millions of people
i couldn't put millions of people in a
room but somehow they are in a room
on my social media platforms it's really
remarkable what's happened here
so you know look me up on any platform
and and let's engage
and i invite everybody to do that and if
you like wine
uh go to qbc.com and order a case we'll
ship it to you
for free and you will be just blown away
by the quality of that wine
if you like that video where do you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe